[Music]
gavin
is with us to start off this hour in
kansas city hi gavin how are you
i'm good dave how are you guys doing
better than i deserve what's up
well uh dave i'm a long time listener uh
it's such an honor to speak with you
you know i don't think there's a minute
that's gone by your show in the last two
years that i haven't heard
my goodness thank you yes of course uh
give you a little backstory i'm 19 years
old
i used to be a young idiot and i
graduated high school i
connected myself with your material and
you connected me with anthony and ken
and i've
found myself going to college at a
private university here
in kansas cash flowing the whole thing
through ken coleman's material i
got up off my lazy button went and got a
job in sales i make about four thousand
dollars a month and i'm having no
problem cash flowing my degree
i'm quadruple major and four years here
business administration finance
accounting
um so forth but i had a question for you
dave
um you know going through this endeavor
here
an entrepreneur such as yourself i
really wondered
at the end of the day what's most
important that i need to be getting out
of my education to be successful in the
marketplace later in life sir
well it's um not a class
in medieval poetry
underwater basket leaving you yeah or
left-handed puppetry
that was my example that's rachel's
example that's rachel's that's a good
one yeah
um so yeah it's um you know so you're
studying things that you're going to use
if you're in business and you're an
entrepreneur
i mean i i was in college 40 years ago
and
almost well i was in college 40 years
ago and um
uh you know this the accounting
principles have not changed
the statistics principles which have
been interesting
in the last week or so to actually know
something about statistics when
people you're watching don't and um it
was it's you know it's a
very interesting uh
to understand that when i'm analyzing
something here inside this business in
other words i use
some of the academic knowledge that you
are training for
that i got similar training of uh there
there was no internet there was no
market there was no
digital marketing but um marketing is
still marketing
and so i use some of the things i
learned in in college
almost every day as the ceo of ramsey
solutions so
i think you're getting very good
training and i'm big on
knowledge i'm big on academics as long
as they have applicable
uses in the marketplace it's when people
study some nuanced corner of
nothing and then are mad because society
owes them something because they can't
get a
job with a medieval poetry degree and so
you know uh that that's what you don't
want to do and you've not done that
you've done a good job i don't know
rachel yeah you got a degree in
communications you use it all the time
yeah i do i mean i would say gavin
there's an element this is not to slam
for your education because we are fr we
are pro college for sure
um but there is nothing like real life
being in business working with people
i mean you can you can learn things in a
classroom but when you apply it to real
life in the real world
it takes a totally different meaning and
so what i would say to you is the fact
that you're working right now i think is
huge like real world world experience
is amazing that's why i tell college
students like go get an internship like
if you think you want to work at an ad
agency that may sound great
sitting in a you know in a in a class
that has 200 people and you're listening
to professor but actually go work there
like see what the work is like so the
fact that you're getting real life
experience
gavin i think is amazing amazing i sold
real estate all the way through college
just like you're selling right now all
the way through college
i think so i've still got stories from
those days i'll say something
the things you're learning in the
workplace i think is extremely valuable
and to not be under the assumption which
you're not gavin i'm not accusing you of
this
that a degree even a quadruple major
isn't going to make you successful in
and of itself that sheet of paper
no it does it isn't going knowledge
gives you a tool in your belt
to be a craftsman in the market to go
out and actually use what you've learned
which you are doing right now
as you're working so it's amazing so i
just there's kind of all sides to it
right like
getting a four-year degree and actually
learning something beyond a high school
level is extremely important and that
degree will get you indoors i mean
there's certain jobs and industries that
require a four-year
college degree and it's amazing so like
that it's going to help you
but don't be under the assumption that
life is going to work exactly how the
professor
in the class says it's going to work and
that just because you get that degree
means you're going to be successful
what you're doing as hard as you're
working right now
to pay cash for this and you're loaded
yourself up academically you've got a
lot of
a lot of stuff going on with the
quadruple major here
what you're doing is very strenuous
uh i i was stressed out
when i was doing what you're doing it's
hard
uh but it's not forever uh in a couple
years you'll be done
and you'll come out with a degree
without the debt with the knowledge
without the debt and you'll have this
tremendous work ethic and the ability to
organize and manage your time
and the other stuff that the other
benefits that are going to come from the
stress and strain that you put yourself
under with a series of choices
um but it what you're doing is really
hard uh
but it's worth it so do it he's making
like 50k a year
i know at 19. it's crazy like it's
amazing roll up your sleeves and stick
with it finish play through it's worth
it
what everything you're doing is worth it
uh you're not going to come out of this
with that with
regrets and uh oh i wish i had worked
less
you know uh you you got plenty of time
to do all kinds of things in your life
you're going to be just fine